Ready to go back to Derry?
The first trailer for It: Chapter Two has
arrived, and it looks like writer-director
Andy Muschietti might just pull it off again.
"Hello."
Though most of the clip is devoted to one
scene, there are a few small but telling details
that you might have missed.
Spoilers ahead!
Meet Mrs. Kersh.
Most of the trailer finds Beverly Marsh returning
to her father's old home.
The new resident seems like a nice enough
old lady, doesn't she?
Meanwhile, Bev is heartened to discover the
old "January embers" poem that Ben wrote for
her so many decades before.
But the atmosphere in the apartment grows
eerier by the second, especially when Mrs.
Kersh's starts verbally tormenting Beverly:
"I was always daddy's little girl.
What about you?"
If you read Stephen King's massive novel It,
you'll remember this moment as one of the
creepiest scenes in the book.
In the novel, Mrs. Kersh transforms into a
yellow-toothed witch.
The trailer doesn't quite show us what she'll
become in the movie, but we're already covering
our eyes.
Here's another detail from the trailer that
really stands out: The Losers Club appears
to have thinned out.
Although the group still sees young Stanley
Uris and Eddie Kaspbrak in a window reflection,
there are now only five of them standing as
adults: Isaiah Mustafa's Mike Hanlon, Bill
Hader's Richie Tozier, James McAvoy's Bill
Denbrough, Jessica Chastain's Beverly, and
Jay Ryan's Ben Hanscom.
If you read King's novel, you know that Stanley
Uris never makes it back to Derry.
Eddie does join the group for the second battle
against Pennywise, but his fate isn't as fortunate
as the rest.
However, in the book, Eddie's death takes
place late in the action.
Perhaps the glimpse we see in the trailer
is from the tail end of the film, after The
Losers Club's last stand with Pennywise.
Or maybe Eddie just dashed off to the pharmacy
to pick up a new inhaler?
Time will tell.
The settings in the trailer for It: Chapter
Two are entirely familiar.
Evidently, Derry hasn't put much money for
renovations over the last 27 years.
One location seems to carry some major significance,
though, and we're not talking about the sewer,
although there's bound to be plenty of action
down there, too.
No, we're talking about this grassy hill.
As you may recall, it looks like the exact
same spot the kids visited to make their blood
oath in the first film.
"S-swear if it isn't dead, if it ever comes
back, we'll come back, too."
It's also the same spot that both Stan and
Eddie seemed to confirm their fates by leaving
the group first, in the same order they die
in.
Surprisingly, the exit order doesn't seem
to be repeated in this trailer.
If you look closely, it's Richie Tozier who
trails the group instead of Eddie.
You may want to avoid Chinese food for a while.
As we see in the trailer, the Losers Club
heads over to the Jade of the Orient restaurant
for a reunion meal, just like in the book.
"This meeting of the Losers Club has officially
begun."
The trailer only shows their arrival, but
King fans, and anyone who saw the 1990 TV
miniseries, will remember just how unappetizing
things get.
So many unspeakable horrors can fit into those
teeny tiny fortune cookies.
Guess we'll have to wait and see what ghastly
surprises IT has in store.
The trailer also calls back to a fixture of
King's book and the 2017 adaptation: the giant
statue of Paul Bunyan in the town park.
It's there in the first film, when the Losers
gather together to discuss Pennywise.
In the book, it becomes animated and taunts
Richie.
It: Chapter Two brings the statue back into
Richie's life, but we don't see it in motion
just yet.
Instead, Pennywise is seen floating above
it, suspended by an inverted pyramid of balloons.
Even so, the Paul Bunyan statue's importance
clearly hasn't been overlooked by the director.
King fans also know that the statue really
exists in Bangor, Maine, and freaks out the
locals on a regular basis.
The first chapter of It thankfully didn't
deal with the Ritual of Chüd or Maturin the
celestial turtle, but fans know that these
otherworldly concepts will make it into Chapter
Two.
The trailer appears to confirm it: The Losers
hit the sewers to track down Pennywise and
come upon a giant spiky object.
We see the gang holding hands and looking
up at the ceiling, or, more likely, something
beyond the ceiling.
We never get a glimpse of the creature in
the trailer, but we imagine, we hope, it'll
be more frightening than that thing we saw
in the miniseries.
We know Muschietti plans to bring the inter-dimensional
element of It to the big screen in Chapter
Two, and this is our first look at how that
might happen.
Scared?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.